welcome to your mom's house
I masturbated yeah even though you were
in the room that's I know how weird an
apropos of the show yeah
well cuz we were took a shower together
and I was taunting your kibbles in bed
tonight and I was like I don't know we
have time to really get one in or why
didn't I even suggest that but I was
thinking it in my head I go I don't know
I'll try to get you to participate in
the shower you're like I gotta go in the
shower
move really fucks in the shower I mean
now I think my bones are all out of
whack now okay anyways I wasn't sure
with you although I'm now talking again
and yet you see what I'm trying to do
I'm just trying to set it up and it
starts playing I'm just trying to like
place it
I wasn't sure when blue band would come
over and I didn't know if we had time
there that's the story then you got into
the shower well I saw you going in the
closet and then I saw you come out and
then I was like first actually I didn't
know if you were in the clouds behind
then I was like oh she's not in there I
didn't hear any noise so I was like I
was no one in the room I'll crank one
out yeah and then I did and stuff
happened you know and then I was like
and I was like you want to do it now
let's do it we got a few minutes then
what happened then you go a key and they
blew me loaded yeah did I say it like
that no you went already did it
and he got a stick dick after I tried to
have marital Catholic love with you and
you spilled your seed carelessly in the
shower yep that's true you know what I
was thinking to myself I was like - he's
taking a really long shower and it's not
like you you usually first of all you
don't really clean anything like you
guys blow your nose you shake around
like a dog and then you get out I was
just trying to make sure I was I was
extra quiet I should have been more
I should have done that oh man but I was
I was actually like because I thought
you might have been walking around yeah
that didn't deter you whatsoever I
turned myself away from there it's a
very it's not the ideal bathroom for
masturbating you know pleasantly no
because there's no door between the
bedroom showers and especially once
Ellis starts walking I'm sure he's gonna
want to see you we got time okay you can
walk it in on your dad cranky when is
there anything more scarring didn't your
dad it wasn't raining dad messed um nope
what that might be the only thing I
haven't seen then your parents used to
like not really be big on clothes though
when you're really young yeah well we're
do European it was naked all the time
everybody was nude no weird no I saw my
mom naked all the time
was high my dad naked all the time I had
a friend come over when I was like 11
and she was like your dad's naked I'm
like oh yeah dad could put on something
there's a friend he's like oh okay why
no I think he first went why like why
wait where would he be naked in the
backyard we lived in Canoga Park in the
backyard and he liked to sunbathe nude
that was what he was doing she's always
naked in the backyard I should preface
it by saying and whoever was over
whatever girlfriend they're naked in the
backyard just sunbathing that's very
natural and that doesn't strike you now
as really bizarre though no because
because when you grow up with naked
parents no no but now you have
perspective so no if Alice saw me nude
if I don't think I'd give a shit I still
don't think so
I don't care well it's not sexual there
were European babe your Panzers naked no
it's only Americans are uptight about
nudity no okay if you're European write
in and let us know that it's normal
everybody's naked they're not gonna tell
you it's normal so what about my dad
drinking a 12 or every night I think
it's normal for a man to be nude around
10 and 11 year olds and then and then
you go put on some clothes things like
why right
that's the thing is that I had to tell
my dad that that wasn't appropriate in
America that you can't just be naked
why isn't appropriate anywhere else
though I don't think it is yeah maybe so
but then he started putting on like
bought on just one people were over and
then eventually I became a teenager and
then he covered up yeah but when I
became a teenager he stops but you're
ten and eleven yeah nude yeah walking
around the house nude yeah yes everybody
my family yes my mother was naked all
the time
tops and bottoms tops bottoms I've seen
my mom I don't like clothes her vagina
like a ton of times all the time yeah
it's just normal was normal babe my mom
had big soggy hangers that's topless you
said a new naked yes she came out of the
shower and she would be talking to me
like we get ready hmm 400 and then my
mom would like run through the house and
go to the kitchen naked to grab
something as she was coming on the chart
it wasn't like we were nudists but if
somebody took a shower and then like had
to grab something another part of the
house they just crawl you know walked
around okay well you never saw anybody
Charl no Todd zarg seen a masturbate of
course but like that's like a very
common bonding thing for most for most
fathers and sons of America no I'm
serious so but you've seen your dad's
not simple and dick yeah but not a lot
and not on like it's like on accident
like walking in you know he's changed
yeah but not not with any regularity
ever yeah people just walk around it
wasn't it wasn't like a lifestyle but
you know yeah you actually have another
person in the room did tiny normal he
crab normal well yeah we're trying to
we're trying to establish was normal
right Americans both Israeli parents as
Raley's are nudists aren't thank ina so
I'm learning at my childhood way fucked
up I didn't realize it so I'm four years
old
sweetie would you what's your vote
well I'm not working on my dad how about
the idea of just nudity just kind of
been walking around that's weird
that's weird yeah Jews are funny well I
don't like if Ellis walks in on me
changing what am I supposed to know yeah
but that's different that's totally
don't see the difference it's walking in
on you changing and you being like I'm
just laying around with my dick out
excited your friend over here you're ten
what's up
like you don't think that's yeah it's
true never thought of it that way who's
so normal yeah it must have really been
normal to you it was it wasn't like
erotic it didn't feel sexy or anything I
didn't think I thought it felt sexy my
dad like how you take it there felt sexy